[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هولندا تفجرها على طريقه بيلاروسيا ولكن
باسلحه نوويه امريكيه وموسكو تتواعد بالرد
وبقوه والمجر تعلنها البقاء للاقوى ولا
مكان للضعفاء في هذا العالم اوروبا تتحضر
لاحداث مهمه في اوكرانيا الفتره المقبله
يطلق عقوباته يمنه ويسرى مدير الاستخبارات
الامريكيه في زياره سريه
والاغرب من ذلك اتصال لاستخباراتي عالي
المستوى بين موسكو واشنطن فما الذي يحاكم
من تحت الطاوله والاداره الامريكيه بين
خيارين احلاهما مر والسبب اوكرانيا كره
النار تتدحرج في فرنسا وتكبر بسرعه مهوله
والسلطات في ورطه بكين تنهي اي فرصه
للتجسس الامريكي على اراضيها واليابان
وتايوان تشاهدان بصمت
في مي الاقليميه واشنطن بين مطرقه روسيا
وسندان اوكرانيا
الوضع يزداد قتامه وسوداويه وكلما قلنا
عساها تنجلي قالت الايام هذا مبتداها وهو
مثل عربي يحكي حال الحرب الاوكرانيه التي
تزداد تعقيدا بمرور الايام وهنا دخلت
بولندا على خط الازمه ولكن بشكل اعمق هذه
المره وذلك بعد ان طلبت وارسو من حلف
النيتو نشر اسلحه نوويه امريكيه على
اراضيها لتقتدي بالجاره الاخرى لاوكرانيا
بيلاروسيا التي نشرت اسلحه نوويه روسيه
فهل وصل الامر ببولندا لنشر اسلحه نوويه
من البولنديين يخافون من رده فعل الدب
الروسي بعد ان اشعلت وارسو فتيله توترات
مع موسكو اوبا شكلها هتولع يا جدعان ليجيب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي لمترميد معبرا عن
اعتقاده بان النشر المحتمل لاسلحه نوويه
امريكيه في بولندا يهدد باستخدامها بشكل
فعلي لاحقا مضيفا وعلى الاغلب يثير سرور
هؤلاء الاغبياء المجانين كونا القرارا
النهائي بهذا الخصوص سيعود لعجوز اصابه
الخرف يتواجد خلف المحيط ويقصد بايدن وعلى
ذات الصعيد لكن في سياق الحرب الاوكرانيه
قال رئيس الدبلوماسيه الاوروبيه في مقابله
مع قناه ان احداثا مهمه للغايه تنتظر
اوكرانيا خلال الرئاسه الاسبانيه لمجلس
الاتحاد الاوروبي واضاف بوريلا انها
مرتبطه بما سيحدث في ساحه المعركه
وبمفاوضات خفيه في الظل الى حد ما بهدف
انهاء النزاع فهل فهمتم شيئا مما قال
دعوني اجيبكم انا بحسب ما نفهمه من
الاوضاع الراهنه
[موسيقى]
ان تفوض وهذه الاراضي لا زالت بيدها قبل
الحرب وقبل كل تلك الخسائر لكن هذا الخبر
في الصحيفه يؤكد ما قاله فيكتور لان
البقاء للاقوى فلا تفاوض مع الطرف الخاسر
الامر لن ينتهي بعد وهنا افادت صحيفه بولس
جورنال الامريكيه ايضا بانز اجرى اتصالا
بمدير المخابرات الروسيه عقب تمرد مجموعه
فاجنر وهنا اتضح الامر اكثر فالتفاوض لا
يكون الا مع الاقوى والحقيقه فان الاداره
الامريكيه تقف بين رغبه في تقدم ميداني
القوات الاوكرانيه ومساعي
للجلوسكوا الى طاوله التفاوض وهما خياران
احلاهما مرسي يكشف رئيس هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه المشتركه الجرر المارك ميلي ان
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد يسير بشكل ابطا
مما كان متوقعا
ان الهجوم المضاد سيكون صعبا وطويلا
ودمويا للغايه وهنا وبعد ان زار رئيس
الوزراء الاسباني
ليظهر دعم الاتحاد الاوروبي الراسخ لطلب
اوكرانيا الانضمام الى الاتحاد ليؤكد
انضمام اوكرانيا سيكون ضمن اولويات
الرئاسه الاسبانيه الدوريه للاتحاد
الاوروبي والتي بدات بالامس لتعود بنا
عجله الاحداث نحو الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث
وقع الرئيس الاوكراني
على مرسوم يفرض عقوبات على
193 شخصا معظمهم يحملون الجنسيه الروسيه
وكذلك ضد 291 شركه من روسيا ومن دول اخرى
لم يكتفي بذلك لوقع اوامر باقاله رؤساء
مناطقسكيت العاصمه لم يكشف سبب هذه ربما
تكون بسبب الملاجئ المغلقه اثناء الغارات
الروسيه وعلى ذكر الغارات اعلنت الدفاع
الروسيه عن توجيه ضربه ناجحه لمواقع
القياده الاوكرانيه العمليه والتكتيكيه
لمجموعه
باسلحه عاليه الدقه تمركزها ارضي وبحري
فيما قال الجيش الروسي ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تكبدت خسائر في الارواح
والعتاد خلال محاوله تقدم وحداتها قرب
بخموت وهنا يستمر الامريكانو بمتابعه
احداث الانقلاب الفاشل في روسيا لينقل
موقع
الملقب بجنرال يوم القيامه محتجز جنوبي
روسيا ومن المحتمل انه يتم استجوابه داخل
مقر القياده العسكريه في مدينه رستوف التي
استولت عليها فاجنر خلال التمرد قبل
الانسحاب منها والان ندري من اين ياتون
باخبار كهذه رغم ان نفى الامر ونفته
الدفاع الروسيه ومن البر ينتقل الروس الى
ما وراء البحار حيث قالت وزاره الدفاع
اليابانيه انها رصدت سفينتين للبحريه
الروسيه في المياه بالقرب من تايوان
وجزيره اوكينا واليابانيه في الايام
الاربعه الماضيه وذلك في اعقاب اعلان
مماثل من تايوان قبل ايام
الهاويه الفرنسيه
كره نار تتدحرج في فرنسا وتكبر اكثر فاكثر
وبسبب الاحداث التي تعيشها باريس
لمراهق برصاص الشرطه ليتم الاعلان عن مصرع
عشريني خلال الاحتجاجات افراس سقوطه من
اعلى سطح متجر هذه الاحداث لا تمر مرور
الكرام على فرنسا حيث قالت قناه
انه تم اضرام النيران في اكثر من 1300
سياره
و24 مبنى فرنسا خلال اول ليله اثناء اعمال
الشغب التي اندلعت بعد مقتل الفتى على يد
الشرطه وكان القدر يعطي فرنسا كاسا مما
تذوقه العرب خلال احداث الربيع العربي فما
رايكم بهذا المذاق لنكمل بينما اعلنت
الرئاسه الالمانيه ان الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ارجى زيارته الرسميه الى المانيا
بسبب تداعيات الازمه في البلاد ليصل عدد
من اوقفتم شرطه الفرنسيه نحو الف شخص في
ارجاء البلاد مع نشر الداخليه الفرنسيه
اكثر من خمسه واربعين الف شرطي للتصدي
لاعمال العنف والاضطرابات الجاريه